when mankind was created he was given a
salt this soul gave him the clarity to
perceive the world around him and man
prospered but whatever created man also
placed to solve devouring demon upon the
earth it's almost as if whatever
designed man did not believe in his
creation the old one with its insatiable
appetite for salt lay in slumber waiting
completely naive mankind learned how to
unlock the potential of his soul and the
world was United owing to the soul arts
not much history of this time remains
but we know that mankind prospered under
a benevolent rule perhaps by the old
king to run the people were happy time
passed and mankind spread across the
earth but the divine creator decided
that there was a price to pay for
progress a lust for power awakened the
old one and the colorless deep fog swept
across the land spreading through the
cities of man out of the fog came
terrible demons hungering to devour and
reclaimed souls for the old one
mankind looked to face a steady
extinction and soon over half the world
had been erased by fog but against all
odds a few humans managed to lull the
old one back to its slumber the fog
retreated but innumerable souls had been
lost forever this event came to be known
as the first scourge
in the aftermath of the first scourge
the fabric of the world was unstable so
monumentals were appointed to the Nexus
a central point linked to six corners of
the kingdom these monumental sacrificed
themselves and became half living
sentinels of reality with no immediate
threat peace was had for a time the sole
arts were banned
so the mankind would never awaken the
old one again but mankind has a short
memory
so he's destined to relive the past one
by one the monumentals died and they
were not replaced the kingdom of
boletaria rose again after the first
scourge this time without the knowledge
of the soul arts behind this kingdom was
king allant
the 12th magnanimous ruler who cared for
his subjects and fought valiantly
against the remaining vile and depraved
demons of the first scourge in his old
age Alon became melancholy the soul arts
had been forgotten by most but they
still existed and eventually Alon
discovered Nexus and with a newfound
thirst for power he went there and
learned the soul arts but who taught him
trapped within the Nexus along with the
old one is an immensely powerful demon
her powers date back to the first
scourge where she was able to suck out
the soul of any creature instantly
killing them a prisoner of the Nexus her
powers contained the candle maiden tends
to the lights of the Nexus and to the
souls that are bound there we can't know
for sure where alarm learnt of the soul
arts but when he left the Nexus he left
with the ability to suck Souls from the
living with the revived knowledge of the
soul arts boletaria experienced
unprecedented prosperity and just like
before the wheel of time began to turn
again King allant wanted more no longer
satisfied with his power he took the
black blade sole brand a blade designed
for demonic souls in a desperate bid for
power he once more ventured to the Nexus
and this time a work for long forgotten
old one from its slumber and so began
the second scourge the folk has spread
out once more and the kingdom despairs
no one has heard from the king and the
demons have overrun Imola tauriel as the
fog spreads the rest of the world hears
rumors or is from other lands speak of
the enticing power of demon souls the
demons consume the souls of humans
enriching their own demon souls and the
power of a mature demon soul is beyond
human imagining the fog will eventually
swallow the world but no one who enters
the fog returns but you need to enter
for one of two reasons brave soul
is not done
I shall guide you
so that you may love the old one back to
summer as the land found its Savior or
have the demons found a new slave